مع اذان المغرب اعتاد الكثير من المصريين
وغير المصريين الافطار على موائد الرحمن
تلك الموائد التي يقوم على اعدادها اهل
الخير كل سنه وتزداد اهميتها هذا العام مع
تزايد الازمات الاقتصاديه وارتفاع الاسعار
في منطقه الدراسه مائده عامره استمرت على
مدار سنوات لم تنقطع الا بسبب منع اقامه
الموائد خلال تفشي جائحه الكورونا وعلى
مقربه منها في الجماليه دفع غلاء الاسعار
بثلاث جمعيات للتكاتف لتنظيم مائده الرحمن
في الماضي كانوا يشترون باسعار مخفضه ولكن
ليس هذا العام ما نزلناش في الاسعار زي كل
سنه ناخد باسعار طبيعيه بس طبعا ما بتقدرش
تنزل لان الدنيا غاليه على الناس كلها على
قد ما بنقدر بنعمل ديل مثلا مع حد بيورد
لنا رز ومكرونه بنعمل ديل مع جزار يورد
لنا البروتين وهكذا اما في حي المنيره فقد
تحولت المائده التي كانت تقام في الشارع
الى وجبات ساخنه يق اهل المنطقه باعدادها
وتعبئتها وتوزيعها على المحتاجين وحتى بعد
رفع الحظر على اقامه الموائد بقي الحال
كما هو احنا خايفين من الغلا بس لان الناس
الغلابه كتير جدا جدا جدا مش هنلاحق
فضلنا اننا نعمل
العلب احنا قلنا الاحوط اللي احنا نعمل في
المائده نعمل وجبات احسن ما نعمل في
الشارع وهيبقى المجهود وهيبقى المجهود
مضاعف بحيث ان ربنا سبحانه خفف عن الناس
اللي شغالين معنا في المعده وفي نفس الوقت
ربنا يكرمنا بعدد وجبات اكتر ان شاء الله
رب العالمين توزيع الوجبات ايضا يعفي
البعض من حرج التواجد في الموائد على غير
المعتاد ففي ظل الازمه الاقتصاديه وغلاء
الاسعار تكتسب اعمال التكافل الاجتماعيه
اهميه خاصه سواء التي تقوم بها جمعيات
خيريه او افراد
تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره